hey what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close I'm Geo and I'm
Bart and this week I want to talk and
kind of flip the script on you because
last week you asked me about my kind of
kind of a microcosm of the little world
I was growing up in so you started off
by saying like we've known each other
since 2008 we've been together for a
total of 15 years and we literally know
everything about each other right yeah
um but the surface level no on a deep
level what the hell are you talking
about think you know me deeply a hundred
percent like I can make decisions on
your behalf what the [__] are you
talking about dude okay what if I go to
uh McDonald's right now what am I gonna
order uh so you're gonna get chicken
nuggets you're gonna get a coke with
extra ice
um it depends on kind of your mood too
you don't always get a [__] what is
that fish thing called fish fillet yeah
you don't always get a fish fillet but
who knows you might be feeling saucy
that day I'll kind of have to fill you
out and if you do get a fish fillet then
you probably will get a spray but if not
then you're just probably gonna stick to
uh what's that burger the [__]
Quarter Pounder what is it called see
and you're gonna get it wrong I just
don't know the McDonald's menu like you
know the McDonald's menu the Double
Quarter Pounder with Mac sauce yep yes
yeah and you want it all large what the
[__] are you talking about and then put
me on a deep level
that's your cage if I know your [__]
McDonald's order yep and I know I'll
never get it wrong because I have your
orders on my phone oh yeah yeah what
about what's my Taco Bell order
well they don't have the pizza anymore
no I only get one you get a steak
[__] chalupa
you know me okay you passed the test
that's it that's the test you're so wet
do you know someone's McDonald's and
Taco Bell order
that's how you know what's my Taco Bell
order
you get the Crunchwrap Supreme
and then the [__] uh nachos
no I don't get it
is that what you said okay anyway so
yeah then last week you were talking
about
um how we've been together for 15 years
we do know a lot about each other but
you know we haven't lived
the lives that we like we I can't go
into your military career for example
and actually see all the ins and outs of
it because it's only been experienced
through your eyes and your eyes only so
that's sad
that I can't experience it with you like
when you get to know someone you don't
get to experience what they experience
yeah you just get to experience that are
traumas
oh I mean if you put it that way yes you
know what I mean like you don't get to
experience like when my mom was loving
and caring you just get to experience
the result of me getting [__] up by my
mom and now I'm throwing it all on you
and then likewise same thing you know
yeah like the person that's like like
scared of dogs like I don't get to go oh
at the time that Jill was happy with the
dog I just get the deal that was like
I never will have a dog yeah yeah I
don't see it that way so when you
pitched it that way just now I was like
oh [__] I never
consider it that way because the way I
look at it is the way I see it be sad is
that I don't get to know the truth
right not that not that it's a lie yeah
yeah but you get my version yeah I get
your version of what it really was like
so if we go like if you were to tell me
about a fishing story and you're like
yeah man I was so good at fishing I
caught a fish this big but if I'm there
then I'm like no it wasn't that big it
was actually I'm such a hater it was
this big yeah it could be bigger it was
that big or like no you're actually
really good or no you actually really
really suck that's why I think
um military guys love
talking with other military guys to kind
of gauge how their perspectives were ah
oh you know yeah like or even people
have been through a specific unique
things yeah oh wait your parents were in
that cult too dude did you do this did
you do this because I think even with
Hobbies too you also get to see their
level of like
um uh devotion that they had for it like
if I'm talking to someone else let's say
about volleyball because we did talk
about another in the other episode about
my career and that not even a career but
like my time playing it
um if I talk to someone else that plays
like if they're like oh you played
volleyball too I'll start you know
engaging in that conversation and then
I'll start asking questions to kind of
see where their skill level is at and be
like oh okay cool yeah
yeah so that is it's cool but that's my
sad version of it where I'm like oh I
don't really get to see if you were as
badass or as like shitty as you say you
were like you were probably the opposite
of it or like you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah so for you for this week I do
want to cover more of like your military
career and like the stories and
everything that happened there because I
do get Snippets of it and it sounds
because it's coming from you you know
you're an ultra positive person and you
do see the lesson and everything so I
think you give it to me already super
filtered yeah
um where it seems like it wasn't really
a big deal or like a big bother and
honestly it seems like you had a lot of
fun like the stories sound gnarly
because sometimes you're getting your
ass beat and you're getting like clowned
on and it just sounds like it was like
physically excruciating but it sounds
like it was always fun times well I
think military teaches you how to have
fun
you know how like uh what do they say
like the um
there's a phrase that's like like the
hardest present makes your Fondest
Memories um
it's like that yeah where like the
military is like the ultimate definition
of that like when it's a [__] hard as
[__] and you want to quit and like
nothing is going your way like there's a
term in the military called embrace the
suck like don't fight it just embrace it
like give me more give me more
um those are the stories that you share
over campfires yeah not like oh dude I
had a whole pound of like Sara Lee pound
cake and it tastes delicious everyone
yeah you don't remember that [__] this
guy's boring yeah so like uh I think the
military is the definition of how do you
make hard things fun yeah and I think
the better you are at it the better you
do in the military yeah okay so
um what is a memory right now that
sticks out to you
the one that has been sticking out as of
recent the most is my uh two hour fire
watch every night okay so explain that
how do you what is a fire watch
how old were you and how'd you get into
that how did that happen so
um
when I don't know if you do this but
like I've been working out for a long
time since I was 15 I'm 39 this year so
24 years and I like to kind of gauge
myself with myself to see like oh is my
cardio better than before is my strength
better than than before
um do I feel like I have less tea than
before or am I recovering tea
testosterone testosterone like I like
the gauge you know my is my recovery
slowing down because everyone says you
know once you get to a certain age like
wow you're a scientist I don't do that
yeah yes do I feel like my recovery it
takes longer to recover
um do I feel less mobile
um do I feel less like drive to train
like I like to like kind of piece all
those things together
and when I piece them all together right
now I actually feel like I'm in the best
shape of my life so at my current weight
this is the strongest I've ever been
um recovery wise I don't feel the oh if
I do squats you can't move for three
days like I don't feel that you know I
don't feel that
um I don't feel like I'll have too much
saggy titties just yet because I know
like it's inevitable one day I'm gonna
look like Arnold Schwarzenegger where
everything just droops now I feel like
I'm still kind of like perky and tight
um and my cardio is the best it's ever
been so because of that it makes me and
I have actually good vision
so when I take all these things I'm like
dude like at 39 I feel like I'm in my
Peak
shape and I'm at my best self so I take
this person and I'll plug it back into
Old phases and go like
do I think I would I have succeeded more
than I did in the past you know because
like you know like one of the things
that we talked about was like a few
years ago I was actually thinking about
realisting just because I didn't really
feel like I got the most out of my
military career
and I felt like to me and a lot of
people might not agree but boot camp to
me was extremely [__] hard uh no uh
the Marine Corps boot camp and then I
think back on my why was it so [__]
hard for me so you're seeing a lot of
people don't agree that boot camp is
hard no no boot camp is for sure hard
okay and the Marine Corps bootcamp is
for sure the hardest but there's a lot
of people that don't think
um they were on the verge of quitting
ever
they just realized it was hard but for
me a boot camp I felt like I was on the
verge of quitting almost every single
week I just toughed it through all the
time and I think back and I think the
hardest thing that made it so difficult
was my two hour fire watch because I got
framed for something in the beginning of
boot camp so in the beginning of boot
camp so in boot camp they have as much
physical training as there are there's
[__] what they call like [__] [__]
games like mind [__] games too yeah yeah
because you need to be mentally tough
yeah and uh physically tough so
physically obviously you're doing
jumping jacks pull-ups running fine with
the psychological warfare yeah you have
that then randomly everyone's standing
at attention at their bunk they're like
okay
so I know someone in here stole the
peanut butter from the child Hall and
you can go down and probably do a
polygraph test [__] hold their pulse
and you'll find out no one's stolen
thing it's just an excuse to play [__]
[__] games now so now everyone everyone
open your [__] Foot Locker which is
like the little Locker that you keep on
your [__] dump it on the [__] ground
now so everyone's dumping all their [__]
on the ground the Drone starts are
flying through the middle kicking
everyone's [__] like kicking my clothes
into your clothes his underwear to his
underwear making you take off your boots
him put up his uh put on him taking the
beds throwing on the ground the sheets
pillows just imagine a [__] tornado
goes through all right now you have 60
seconds to clean this [__] up now 65 90
and everyone's just [__] just mind
[__] games to the max you know and in
one of those mind [__] games I forgot
how but I got in trouble for something I
didn't do so I got assigned two hours
firewatch and what firewatch is you know
at a military base when you're camped
out like let's say you're gonna go to
war not everybody can go to sleep
because the enemy can come and just
[__] kill your ass right of course so
every single hour you have one person
assigned to wake up within that hour and
kind of do a patrol and make sure
everything is cool so it might be like
you have nine o'clock shift so you go
you're walking around at 10 or maybe 9
45 you come wake me up hey Juan it's
your turn so I get I put my clothes on
and then you can't go to sleep until I'm
up to make sure that the Baton is passed
I'm up I go walk around 10 45 go to
someone else hey it's your turn and then
they wake up and so that way every so
everyone only had one hour but you had
two hours well there's 90 people so some
people don't even have it every night
you know some people might only get it
like once a week like one hour of week
of of sleep missing or some people might
even get it once a month because there's
a lot of people to rotate they just want
to make sure you get a taste of it not
that it's a punishment I got two hours
every night
so if everyone is already what did you
do I forgot but I didn't do it and so
every uh
every night if everyone only slept six
hours I only slept four and that
happened the entire um what is it called
three months second phase of boot camp
second phase is when you go into the
mountains and you learn how to shoot and
stuff how long was that
uh 30 days and that's when I remembered
having a fever the entire 30 days of
boot camp so I think that's why I was so
[__] hard because I remember like um
you know when you have like body aches
and pains yeah I remember we'd be
getting on gravel and you're learning
how to shoot from the prone and I would
go and I'm like oh like my elbows would
[__] ache and everything was was
hurting and I'm like looking around I'm
like [__] is it just me because no one
knows what a a month-long
fever feels like and body aches you know
so I'm like what the [__] and then I
feel really lethargic I can't really
move or anything like that and then
finally it the the final culmination is
when I got strep throat at the end of it
and that's when I was like the [__] is
that phone you oh that was when um
uh my my body was burning hot like crazy
so I wanted to make sure I finished The
Crucible The Crucible is like the final
event in second phase two it's like the
hardest event in boot camp uh that you
have to finish before you become the
student I mean not that I expect you to
but that's tight that you didn't go I
don't want to [__] out on that I want
to make sure to finish The Crucible
because from the beginning everyone
tells you about The Crucible it's like a
three-day event
50 miles on foot full pack go do all
these like 10 20 obstacle courses and
stuff so I want to make sure I did that
so after I did that I came back my body
was on fire and that's when I go and you
that's when you can request attention
from your drill instructor go boom boom
boom on this recovery what are you
hitting let's do it like a wall there's
like this little wooden panel that you
hit it's called requesting Mass I think
it's called requesting Mass but you
pretty much like you just want to speak
to someone they'll go do this recruit
request speech permission to drill
instructor or whatever
and then he comes out and then I was
like this recruit believes he has a
fever so and he goes how the [__] do you
know he chokes me he goes holy [__]
you're burning up like that's that's his
[__] thermometer you know like
holy [__] you're [__] burning
oh my God so it had to take me to like
the the hospital but
um that's the memory that's been on my
mind the most is oh my damn
had I because I think maybe that might
have been the first like
um theme that made me check out of the
military
but like the first layer of burnout
because you know burnout comes in phases
yeah so I think that could have been
where that was like the first one I was
like [__] that was so unnecessarily hard
and then that made me maybe go like I
just want to focus on school yeah I just
want to get out of here and so maybe
when I had like more opportunities
because my unit was super [__] cool
like they did all kinds of course
jumping jumping out of airplanes and
whatever I think when there's more
opportunities with different schooling
to come up maybe that's why
subconsciously I didn't know but I
turned it down because I was like well
that was [__] crazy I might as well
just keep with the whole school thing I
got into UCLA anyways yeah yeah you know
yeah because you were like well where is
this even gonna take me yeah you didn't
know so I think that that's as a reason
that has been like the memory on my mind
where like if I didn't get the two hours
fire watch every night had I might have
had a different experience you know and
then after you go there where else do
you go
your boot camp no no your head open your
leg in my head
um then after that I think that's it
just ends the it's just because there's
nothing I can control yeah so it's just
like
okay
um
but I also do think that like there's
still a part of me that always feels
like
like I didn't get the most out of it
yeah so I think that's why I'm always
like taking these tactical courses and
I'm like what can I do to kind of like
make up for a lost time what can I do to
kind of brush up my skills to whatever I
think it should have been yeah had I
graduated there okay so had you
graduated there I mean like had I like
maximized all the classes I could have
done okay and what were some of the
things that
um that you didn't maximize
that I did it Matthew yeah yeah that
you're like [__] I didn't I didn't get
to do that so I didn't go to jump School
everyone in my union went to jump school
and you were the only one that didn't do
it um and how did that work one of the
few
so did you sound like a wave and you're
like no I don't want this so my unit is
an Anglican unit which is air Naval gun
liaison company so my unit is
um when they say air navel it's like
controlling the skies controlling the
planes it's like an amphibious attack
and the mind controlling the sky and
controlling the planes you mean the
ships the ships destroy the ships
controlling the skies
um so it's people like uh going in the
front lines of the battle like my unit
is full of Ford observers those are the
guys that jump out of planes go super
forward kind of almost like borderline
reconnaissance type stuff and then able
to like locate where we need to be and
then they come and you knew that this
was all happening I didn't know uh like
when you're when you're in it like when
you when that's why I think I also
signed up with the wrong mindset I
signed up with the mindset of like so
wait when you signed up was this after
boot camp when you signed up
no you go to it so you go to the
recruiting office yeah oh that is your
sign up the steps is this you go I want
to be in the military so you go to
Recruiting office and you go out on a
list so in the enlistment path they'll
tell you your job that you get to pick
and then they go this is what you what I
want they go okay cool you gotta take
the ASVAB if you pass it and you get the
right score you can get that so I went
into that going I'm going to go to
college anyways you want a bare minimum
stuff almost none of that stuff even
really mattered and they might have told
me how cool my unit was but I was like
you're like yeah but it's only temporary
so I think none of it had I been really
really present yeah you know so it
wasn't until like I think almost when I
um when I was in then I talked to all my
other buddies at units I'm like what did
you do for drill and they're like oh I
just did this all day I was in the
office all day what'd you do for
drilling I did this like what did you do
I'm like dude I've seen [__]
airplanes fly through the sky I've been
in uh uh like Humvee attack simulators
what do you mean you've seen airplanes
fly in the sky don't we all see that
like Jets and [__] oh okay Jets and
missiles and [__] gunfire like I like
the movie [__] yeah you know like most
people and even then because you're such
a like uh you're such a like a guys guy
and you love like anything that
challenges your physical strength your
mental capacity like you just love
getting in it when you were looking at
all these things you still weren't
curious
because that's me now I think me having
slight regret it made me who I am now uh
and when I'm in it I'm so past it you
know I'm in it I'm so UCLA gotta become
a doctor
um like I didn't I don't think I had the
uh time and even the bandwidth to
appreciate the presence I see I see so
then what were more of the things so
yeah yeah I know I didn't let you get
into how you were able to not go to jump
school yeah but what were some of the
things that you got to experience then
looking back at it that made it cool
yeah so uh or just in general I guess
just anything any memory that you have I
had the coolest [__] unit in the
world okay so so like um so my my job is
Supply yeah usually Supply guys they're
in a warehouse because they're keeping
track of inventory for the whole unit
like anything that you need literally
from the highlighters to staplers to
first aid kits to to yours kevlars to
everything yeah everything you need bars
yes yeah that's literally what supplied
it so all my Supply friends are in a
warehouse
um at my unit we also have Supply
because every unit has like all the jobs
but my unit because it's almost like
Special Operations capable like they
support a lot of like the special ops
guys my unit does a lot of cool [__] and
with a cool unit comes a cool culture so
for example a typical unit might be like
um all right guys we're gonna go on a 10
mile Moto run Moto run meaning like this
is something let's just get the whole
group together and we're going to have
some camaraderie has nothing to do with
requirements or anything let's just go
and then we'll struggle together they
might go oh the admin guys uh you guys
stay back you know don't mind Spike it's
cool like exclude them
in a
in a uh more Elite unit they there's
none of that everyone's doing everything
so
um even when but the job still needs to
be done in Garrison meaning like back at
home base that still needs to be done so
they'll go I need every section to send
two guys
so every single like super cool field
exercise at least for my first two years
in the Marine Corps I was sent there
because I was the junior which is super
cool what's one of the super cool Fields
so I'll explain some of them but like
all the field training exercises which
in retrospect is what looks cool it's
tough in the moment but in retrospect
that's the cool [__] like the 20 mile
hikes the 30 mile hikes those things
um I got sent to all of them so I think
that even had further burnout oh I bet
because I got there going okay cool I'm
just doing supplies I'm gonna do Supply
I just want to inventory some [__] I'm
gonna study I'm gonna get it I'm gonna
go to UCLA I'm gonna do whatever and
then I remember showing up like on a
Thursday and thinking I'm gonna go home
at five o'clock
they go no you're staying you're gonna
get on that bus you guys are going to
Camp Pendleton I'm like well [__] where
am I coming back
Sunday night at like eight or nine I'm
like the whole weekend they're like yeah
because you're going and I'm like what
the [__] and then so for the first two
years my college was [__] but I did
cool [__] so
um one of the coolest things I
experienced was
um in the military
you always hear what these cool like
special ops stuff like Special
Operations like secret you know like
units and stuff and with Instagram a lot
of those guys come to light a lot of
people know David Goggins a lot of
people know Tim Kennedy because their
situations in the story is so unique it
becomes widely publicized but before the
age of social media
like knowing a Navy Seals existence or a
force Recons existence you never meet
them it's a unicorn yeah you meet a ton
of people from the Army ton of people on
the Marine Corps or whatever but you
don't meet there yeah why would they be
there where you're at yeah but you
always hear these things you know and
then you hear that they go by their own
and you're like oh [__] what the [__] so
um one of my first training we went into
Camp Pendleton and then passed the
initial guard Gates we would go to
another like two other almost like gated
communities within the community and
then I I saw something that said like
Mount or whatever training and there are
certain uh training areas that you go
wait I know that that's where I heard
that's almost like going like entering
into area 51. you know when you go into
Area 51 like this is where I hear the
aliens are like you would hear like
certain terms you're like that's when I
overheard that Force Recon or Navy Seals
train or whatever you know so I would be
on the bus and we would enter and then
uh and in the Marine Corps everyone goes
by rank one person that's one rank above
you you're like yes Corporal yes
sergeant and it's like every scene it's
almost like being Korean like like I'm a
three months older than new wow you know
it's like that so it's it has that feel
when we got there this Corporal which is
not too high of a guy comes up and then
talks to
um our commanding officer like buddy
buddy hey what's up man like you never
say man it's like yes sir no sir you're
talking about officer hey what's up man
all right cool all you guys are here
like very just conversational and I was
like
who the [__] is this causing because I
also heard in Special Operations is very
relaxed so I'm like oh yeah you've
already made it yeah I'm like is this
guy one of those mythical creatures
and then I look he's wearing cami's up
top and he's wearing denim jeans at the
bottom you never mix and match clothes
either and I'm like oh [__] this is
[__] him this is [__] him did you
cream I almost did we walk inside then
you see dudes with beards you see dudes
with like earrings and [__] and why are
your beards so crazy so back then uh you
have to be clean shaven now there's a
lot like if you see anybody in military
uniform and they have full beards it's
more than likely the special operations
and they're trying to like integrate
into the countries that we're in so
seeing some with the full like even a
five o'clock shadow is no no so go there
guys with full beards not like clean
haircuts earrings and I was just like oh
[__] I'm amongst these [__] so
that was really cool to even like be in
that environment like go into like a
like you know when you watch like a
Marvel movie like top secret high
clearance in the [__] barbed wire on
top of the fence like that kind of [__]
yeah I'll never experience that and then
I have buddies that are even in Infantry
that are supposed to be training with
guns all the time and I'll tell them
have you been to this part of Camp
Pendleton they're like no they've never
been because they're just they're
they're not they don't need to that's
not part of the mission you know so I've
seen people like that I've also seen
like Cutting Edge technology like
because keep in mind I was in the
military from 2003 until 2009. so this
is like almost 20 years ago I've been in
like uh combat simulators so like
imagine a room that is full of uh 360
projector screen nice and you're in a
Humvee like a true Humvee and you're
Manning a machine gun and people are
popping up out of buildings and they're
blasting so imagine like the most
high-tech video game you've ever played
and you got a driver and you're shooting
and there's still buckets around in case
you get a car sick you can just throw up
and then keep blasting back like [__]
like that is like you're like this is
where Navy Seals trained because it's
like the closest you can get without
hurting people without uh wasting ammo
and only small units can come in and do
stuff like this you know your unit got
to do my unit got to do stuff like that
like if you have a big ass [__] unit
with like [__] I don't know a
thousand people you kind of Run a
thousand people through that simulator
yeah but ours is like small there's only
a few hundred of us so I got through and
for my section I was one of the younger
ones so they send me all the time so I
got to do like [__] like that and why
why does your age matter that you're the
younger one
because uh in it's kind of like a
fraternity so the young cats do all the
[__] work and they do all the [__] that
no one else wants to do like no one
wants to so because it sounds like
that's not that none of that sounds like
[__] work it sounds awesome it's
because it's how you get there oh so in
the Marine Corps
you get everywhere on foot so everyone
knows it's 20 miles to get there so do
you want to spend Saturday getting
somewhere on foot with your full [__]
60 pound pack or would you rather be in
the Garrison which is back at home base
in AC you could drive out into town
during lunch get yourself some tacos you
know yeah send the [__] newbies yeah
or like hit the weights you know because
you're not at War so back at home base
you're not doing all those things you
don't want like the field Life Field
life is
4 a.m mornings MREs no shower Gunk on
your face
or AC shower every day restaurant food
that's not even cool you don't see the
cool [__] there you don't see the cool
[__] here but you're comfortable as you
get more senior
you've already done this so you're like
okay Quan you're going to the field you
know got it and then so if you're not
present then you're like [__] I want to
stay in Garrison so I can study and do
all this stuff yeah but if you are so if
I could turn back the hands of time I
would go with a completely different
mindset I'm like for sure [__] yeah
we're gonna go do this yeah with these
people then I would have said yes to all
the super [__] cool schools
um like uh
you know jump school like combat water
survival School dive school all that
yeah school so going back to it why was
that so cool for you because it seems
like you just met people obviously these
are High Caliber people but why was that
so cool of a memory for you uh the first
story I said uh on the second fight
simulator one
um the first one so it was cool because
I got to meet them in their environment
I see like I made David Goggins at the
Bellagio signing books got it got it
right I'm not like he's wearing [__]
Under Armor rash guards or some [__]
yeah yeah I got it got it it's like me
it's different meaning Jocko in
Afghanistan for sure and we're on the
same team and we're training yeah than
him like at a book signing or some [__]
yeah or even meeting Michael Jordan when
he's on the ball yeah we're playing
versus later on he's at Nike signing
autographs yeah yeah not cussing like
supers clean cut it's different yeah
like I'm in my boots my camera is my
[__] I'm training with you we're gonna
go [__] clear rooms together you guys
did that yeah yeah how fun look oh yeah
like I've seen like those uh room
Clearing Houses I don't even know what
they're called anymore but it's
technically a two-story building but
it's only one story I mean you got to do
it with them alongside that with them
yeah so you're you're in the room
clearing rooms and then the instructors
are above you and they can see kind of
like that movie SWAT where you can see
all the movement and then they know
where they planned the bad guys and all
stuff like that yeah how did that feel
when you were like oh [__] I'm with them
right now
so when I see them in action when I see
them in action that's dope and then when
it's time for me to do it I'm like can I
go back because I have my Biology book
that I caught oh my God I'm so not
present I had my Biology book that I
Xerox copied in my cargo pocket because
I need to study for my exams so like
every single day that we train I
couldn't wait till like
um week I forgot the [__] military word
but pretty much it's like you you camp
out now you camp out for the night you
pull out your sleeping bag I couldn't
wait so I can go back to study I was so
like checked out wow I know that's what
I think that's why like it made me want
to re-enlist so bad because I'm like man
I [__] missed out on so much stuff
because at the raw mentality yeah wow so
you were like with the Michael Jordan's
and you were still like oh God get me
out of here yeah like imagine like being
at an All-Star camp and then you're like
dude I gotta study for biology
yeah everybody's like [__] biology like
this is this is once in a lifetime if
you flunk this class you could take it
in the spring in the fall yeah again you
can graduate college next year the year
after that like it's always going to be
there this experience is gone I can see
now I have such a better understanding
yeah and that's why every guy that I
meet in the military right now they go
oh I see the same thing in their eyes
you know I can't wait to get out I'm
gonna be a real estate agent oh no I'm
gonna be a cop I'm gonna do whatever you
know I'm like no your career is right
now trust me I'm like these memories
right now get the most out of them or
even people that are like bodybuilders
you know because like we have to run so
much in the Marine Corps that they're
like oh I gotta go PT but later on
they're like that's that's your
foundation for the rest of your life
people don't want to lose your gains and
[__] like that and I'm always like no
dude your career is right now I swear to
God get the most out of it because you
only have one time you can do this yeah
bodybuilding
being a cop real estate agent all that
other stuff you can do it way later as
much as you want but when you have a kid
and you got a family and a house there's
no way you're gonna go back in real list
you know yeah I mean you could do it but
it's just it takes a toll on the whole
family yeah for sure yeah
I get it now yeah um so that's the first
one the second one was the simulator
um and then you did you do that with
those guys uh no that one was somewhere
else oh I see yeah that was a completely
different base
um and why was that so cool for you
because that just didn't exist at the
time like nobody was doing that yeah
like when I compare stories and I was
talking about comparing stories like no
one has my stories how did you do
I don't know if I got a score or
whatever but the fact that I even
like did that you know it's almost like
meeting someone like oh where do you
work I work at SpaceX you do what about
you I do too what do you do I file
papers or whatever what about you oh I
just like fixed the space shuttle like
that you know like the stuff that I do
my stories from same rank same Marine
Corps my stories are way different than
all my friends but in the moment I just
didn't know wow you're like oh I want to
know about [__] biology yeah I just
didn't I just did like bomber yeah I
just didn't know what's another one
another one that was really cool
well the last podcast I touched about a
little bit but like seeing an actual
call for fire
what does that mean so call for fire is
when our Ford observers they jump out of
the plane and
um they land at a certain location then
they call the Jets to come and then
[__] why are they getting dropped off
at a certain location and why do they go
first so they go to kind of like check
out scope out the area send information
back oh yeah there's mountains here
there's whatever here so the Humvees
that we wanted they're not going to make
it you know just kind of like
communication and getting the lay of the
land is that what Don was doing
Don does it at a
extremely high level got it so I believe
he was called the j-tech so Jay tax
um their communication providers and
that sounds lame it does but in the
military under Special Operations think
about someone
jumping from the sky in the veil of the
night
and the energy put black paint on his
face yes so like this is how they like
this is the commercials they call them
green eye demons oh okay because they
have the night vision you have the nvgs
so you just see the green eye demons
come out and BG's okay so you see these
guys jumping out of the sky in the veil
of the night Behind Enemy Lines
unnoticed and Don can set up internet
right there whoa and now he can command
what a badass [__] you can
command be in and send communication to
the entire force
to come and wreak havoc you know but you
need that first guy wreak havoc that's a
good one it's like it's like when you're
like um yeah so it's like a extremely
um
highly skilled skill set you know yeah
okay so scratch what I asked so you're
foreign
high altitude trained or night train or
like Don could jump into the ocean with
a parachute he'll know how to package
parachute in the ocean like
um what a style yeah he's like on a
different level but these guys are still
jumping on the planes they go and they
relay information back and then like
let's say okay cool we need support we
need to blow these [__] up they
call Jets come so this so where are you
at at this point when they're calling
all that so he's on the sidelines I'm on
the sidelines in a seven ton seven ton
is like those big ass [__] military
trucks yeah and I'm getting ready to
pass on MREs
[Laughter]
so when you do field stuff
um if Supply needs to be done you're
still doing your job so in the field I'm
passing that makes sense I'm passing
[__] out that needs to be passed out
yeah so in this case you're the mom
you're passing out the snacks so I'm in
the MREs making sure everyone only gets
one okay yeah yeah not on my watch yep
yeah if I'm passing them out on Fridays
everyone I think gets like six but if
I'm just doing one at a time everyone
only gets one I don't care good for you
I don't care who you are okay good for
you I'm glad you were present for that I
don't care what kind of badass you are
you're only gonna get one you only get
one yeah good for you and uh so I'm in
the seven ton on the side passing out
MREs so during this field training part
what was crazy I'm just so jaded because
I see everyone all of my friends can
jump out of the airplane so I didn't
think it was special so I'm literally
hanging out I mean you're not even on
that I know but I'm so jaded because of
that so I'm like sitting on on the
seventh time my [__] legs dangling
and I still have my flak jacket I still
have my kevlar you know I saw all my
gear because you're in a combat
environment even there even though
you're doing training and I see all my
friends like one by one jump out of the
sky hmm But honestly that's how my [__]
I was so [__] and I see all my friends
jump out and you see one parachute one
parachute one parachute one parachute
one parachute and you see them come down
and then while I'm making fun I'm like
Ah that's [__] Sanchez all right
that's Chavez or whatever that's crazy
because he's like oh cause he's not he's
fat look how fast he's falling so
[__] fat that guy even though he's
the one jumping on the airplane I'm not
passing on MREs
so [__] fat oh man it's gonna be a
crash landing and then you see him come
and then he's impact their parachutes do
whatever qualify and then
like [__] two Jets come
[__]
what are the things falling what is that
I don't know what the [__] they are
anvils or [__] like [__] like
Looney Tunes
I don't know yeah we're trying to get
the [__] Wally coyote
I don't know some sort of [__]
explosives I see way above my pay grade
I don't know what the hell that is yeah
but if you know anything about tax
dollars when I saw that event that just
happened I was like of course you're
calculating the [__] math yeah I was
like dude this is a [__] 10 billion
dollar exercise
the plane that it takes to get these
[__] in the sky to jump out
what about the jet fuel exactly the Jets
the jet fuel it's officers in the Jets
so those guys are super high ranking
dudes they gotta unleash the [__]
things all the MREs I got to keep track
of they gotta pay at least five dollars
five dollars a pop you know yeah so five
dollars a pop yeah so I'll just watch
this whole thing and then it's not until
later on because I didn't really
understand how much later tax dollars
when I was in it but later on when I
started like understanding things I was
like [__] I can't believe I witnessed
like a five billion dollar training
session I'm like
like that
but that was really that that memory
yeah most people never and I mean I hope
I never see that that memory is like
forever like seared into my brain the
yawning part yeah well keeping making
sure no one comes to steal my MREs
did you have the word apron
because that's combat environment so
like did they have a [__] camo no I'm
still wearing candles I'm just [__]
around I know you don't wear a black
jacket I saw my kevlar on I have [__]
camo paint on I have my rifle still yeah
yeah I have all the [__] it's just I'm
doing the [__] work
damn and those are the ones that stick
out to you the most
yeah like just like really cool moments
that
like for one no Supply guys ever see
[__] like that and then number two even
a lot of infantry guys don't see [__]
like that you know was there ever a time
then where you were present that you're
like [__] yeah I'm glad I did this
yes so all the combat water survival
stuff what's that so or what's that like
so um it's like doing Jiu Jitsu in the
water except you're wearing full clothes
so the longer you stay in the water
boots are getting soaked your clothes
are getting and by water you're training
in a pool in a pool yeah
um that stuff because like you know as
good of a swimmer as anyone can get when
you've ever gone a cruise ship and you
fall off you're not falling off
perfectly in swimming trunks and you
know you're falling off in close so like
during those moments because I actually
really love the water I was like oh [__]
this is dope this is like how I would
actually need to learn how to swim I
need to learn how to swim I don't need
to learn about [__] Jets and bombs
boring yeah I need to learn how to swim
with clothes on yeah so all of our
combat water survival stuff it's like
with clothes on and uh so what is that
like and usually in a regular pool
you're not allowed to jump in with
clothes on so I think it's probably the
rebellious it's your if it's your own
pool yeah yeah it's like the mischievous
nature of it like it if I just go to
some community pool and I just jump in
with like t-shirts shorts and shoes yeah
they're like get [__] the [__] out of
here yeah so I think the nature that we
are we need to do that right now all
right taika oh my this is pretty [__]
cool so why was it cool
um just learning different swim
techniques stroke techniques how to turn
in your blouse into like a life jacket
how to turn your trousers into a life
jacket how do you turn your trousers
into a life jacket well you take them
off and then you you tie a knot at the
bottom of the leg bottom of the leg and
then you start blowing it it got wet at
first so that the air doesn't leak and
it turns almost into a balloon you start
blowing air well you first go like this
this is to get your biggest waft of air
then you get your belt you cinch it so
now it's almost like you only get a
latex glove and you blow and turn you
tight now it becomes like this then you
put that the leg uh the pants over your
neck and then you take the two legs and
you wrap it in front of you so now it's
like a life jacket and you constantly
have to splash water on it yes it isn't
dry so yeah it doesn't dry because if it
dries in the air it leaves so you keep
going like that and you can stay a full
for quite a long time like that like
what 20 minutes an hour I don't know we
never tested the limits of it but it
works you can tell this [__]
works yeah sick okay keep going so like
[__] like that I really really enjoy it
and then also like the drowning aspect
or like you have to do these things
where you have to save a victim and of
course of course the victims are swim
instructors panicking so they're going
to come and drown the [__] out of you
like that's what you do Straight rear
naked dunk you into it yeah that's a
different Panic why are they doing what
are they trying to is it are they the
enemy well no they're trying to make it
unrealistically hard so everyone else is
easy oh I see so you actually don't swim
and save them like if if this is the
swim scenario coming to you no I turn
around
so I'm facing that way so that your
instructor's behind you
and then you tread water and you go
backwards and you don't know when he's
gonna grab you and he's splashing water
back your head to like build anxiety the
whole time and you're like don't worry
sir I'm here to save you don't worry we
started here to save me like I'm
drowning I'm drowning and I think they
almost time when you're taking in a
breath because they jump up cover your
mouth and then dunk you in the water oh
[__] dunk you [__] deep into the
water and now they're choking the [__]
out of me they're all jacked too and so
what you're supposed to do is scoop
water this way like a y because people
that are drowning don't like going
deeper so you do three hard Strokes so
by that time you're at the bottom of
like a 10 foot pool then you feel for
like pressure points which is in the
armpit and you and you press deep into
the armpit and then you peel them off
and throw them off and then you go to
the surface so you just let them drown
well you come back up make sure you're
like five feet away because they're
probably gonna work themselves back up
and then you go sir
don't do that again
but you always go sir don't do that
again and then please hold out your arm
so every every life-saving starts with a
attempt of them drowning you first
before you save them oh [__] that's
supposed to be like realistic I guess
you know yeah
yeah so like that stuff was was actually
pretty cool yeah I'm glad you were
present for that because that's cool but
even stuff like that we're like I had a
chance to go to uh the Water Combat
survival school and become an instructor
and I love the water
and then I didn't go like I had chances
to go so like I go to Sears school which
is like survival evasion whatever School
where they teach you how to like kill a
bunny with the bare hand skin it what
parts you can eat what parts you can't
eat you get locked in a box for 17 hours
like hostile hostage style training
so much [__] cool [__] that almost
all my friends did I know where'd you go
I didn't see the for two more or
whatever things and then they'll be like
oh I was at Sears school and oh okay it
just happened and how do they do it they
just sign up
how did they how were they doing it and
you were so unaware of it
um so
they would either sign up or if it's
part of their job that's in their
pipeline oh I see so for example like a
Navy SEAL when you sign up to be a Navy
SEAL it's already lined up of course
like buds jump School dive School
weapons training Land Navigation like
all of it's already lined up so Navy
Seals are actually like I think like two
year pipeline like they're in school for
like two years before they hit their
unit uh so um when when you're in the
military if you have gaps you go to your
unit and then go to the school go to
your unit and you go to your school um
so some guys that get they get to the
unit first and then they're not
technically a full fully qualified like
job yet and then they get sent to their
school and then they come back to the
unit go to school come back to you so if
that unit needs like a specific
position yeah then what do they get
someone in their unit to be like okay
hey you want to we need this guy you
qualify for it to not go to school and
then bring it back yeah they can do that
or they send it to Marine Corps command
and go hey we need a guy like this and
then they send that and then that's like
their HR and they'll search like who do
we have that can do whatever and they
send them yeah so that's how people
transfer units and stuff too yeah yeah
so would you say then that like you're
oh [__] because I just feel like you
don't really remember much because you
were so attracted
I mean I remember quite a bit yeah I
feel like I've uh I've still been able
to share a lot of stories you know yeah
because a lot of it was so cool but it's
just the mindset that I was in at that
time I wasn't really absorbing at all
and then that's the only part that I
feel like that's why I always tell you
I'm like I totally see myself being like
a part-time firefighter now part-time
cop now yeah or like uh I I told you I
didn't want to go to paramedic school
unless you get trained up yeah I guess
before I didn't really understand it
because I didn't get this level of like
yeah for sure for sure that like I'm
like okay I can see you know because you
would tell me on the surface like oh
jump school and I'm like okay you jump
out of a plane but I think now putting
it together in story format and then
like showing me the perspective of
people that were actually down to do it
or it was in their pipeline yeah and and
you kind of just seeing it from the
outside perspective as check that as you
were and then hearing that experience
I'm like [__] that sounds so sick and I
can see why you would have this big
regret yeah like you know when you go on
base yeah and you see I don't know I've
never been on Facebook let's say you go
on base okay you see someone with wings
that's like that's people that jump out
of planes right that's like someone
rocking a Rolex so on base you're like
oh [__] and you could have had that yeah
like they got Wings right yeah that's
Silver Wings that means you only did a
certain amount of jumps gold wings
you're like like really up there and
you're like oh [__] that's like having a
gold rolly at my unit
so if you have wings you wear it all the
time because so [__] badass why would
you never wear it just like if you have
a roller you wear it all the time but
why would you not wear it at my unit so
many people have wings most of them
don't wear it
that's how many people had wings and
that's why I think for me it was so
nothing wow
wow you know because for them they're
like I don't need to wear because we all
have wings we all jump out of airplanes
so it's like that why wouldn't you put
it on like I thought it would just you
don't take it off of the uniform or you
have to take it off you have to take
your yeah you have to wash your uniform
and stuff you can't wash it together no
it's like a metal like badge so they
take it off and on why not leave it on
you have to take it off to put in the
washer I mean what would happen if you
don't take it off probably get scuffed
and start chipping and stuff oh I see
it's metal you know it's like throwing a
Rolex in a in your icy
that's how crazy it was so I had that
attitude but I I so it's like having um
oh you know who has this attitude black
belts black belt and Jiu Jitsu like
you'll go like wait aren't you a third
degree and they're wearing a black belt
with zero stripes on it because to them
they've already hit it so it doesn't
matter it's one two three four five six
seven they don't really give a [__]
about the stripes so you know art like
Takis Jiu Jitsu coach I think he's a
third or fourth degree some of his black
belts don't have stripes on he doesn't
give a [__] who cares white thoughts do
right every single stripe I'm like very
very proud of it yeah so that's how it
is it's like when these guys are [__]
badass everyone's so [__] badass yeah
yeah that they don't have to Peacock at
all they don't yeah I don't have the
peacock and then but so I just got that
side of it without doing the work and
then so for me it just be that's what I
absorbed and I'm like Okay jump School
whatever and it's not until later I'm
like oh [__] not everyone got the
opportunities that I had yeah dang yes I
I I definitely do empathize with you and
I've been empathizing with you with this
regret because you're not someone that
talks about regrets yeah so anytime you
ever do bring a uh up that it is a
regret I'm always very keen to like
listen to it and and whenever I hear
that you want to pursue something that's
I'm always like down for it you know
like you wanted to re-enlist and I'm
like dude taika's barely like a year old
like are you sure you want to devote
that much time away from your family
because like taika's adolescent is so
short yeah
um but I was always still for that you
know like I think you wanted to even do
paramedic
you wanted to be that and I'm like okay
yeah then just do that you know like I
but now more so than ever I'm like oh
[__] I really get where you're coming
from yeah like it's and it's so and you
know me too like I'm a [__] weasel so
I'm trying to always make things work
somehow like recently I even came across
uh Arizona search and rescue page
so all they do is like like helicopters
come the guys come they help save people
like so I'm in the mindset like I want
to use tools to help and save people you
know that's why I'm a little bit iffy
about becoming a part-time cop because I
don't want to enforce the law I like
cool skills to help people that's like
where my heart's at so I saw that and I
was like oh you know what's really close
to Arizona
the Hoover Dam Hoover Dam and in Nevada
so I was like maybe there they have
Arizona like search and rescue team
that's close to Nevada and I could just
drive there for work like 30 40 minutes
a day because we're technically 34
minutes from Arizona so I actually DM
them wow so where's your closest uh
station to Nevada and that one was it
was still like two hours away I was like
okay but I'm all I'm constantly trying
to figure out like how I can get more
involved in
this space this type of training and
stuff you know yeah that's awesome yeah
well thank you for sharing all of that I
feel like they're like I didn't even I
feel like I didn't even scratch the
surface I feel like you could talk about
this whole experience for like three
hours straight
maybe
I mean if you were present enough to
remember any of that [__] no yeah but is
there anything else you want to share
yeah it's pretty badass
you did a bunch of pretty badass [__]
even though you were just
I'm the guy that's probably like
you know like game seven of the NBA
finals and it's like yes I'm the guy
that drives the floor when NBA guys
sweat on the ground
but I was still there yeah yeah I've
never been there and then but I had the
attitude of oh [__] I'm just here to
wipe the floors versus I literally
witnessed the Michael Jordan last dance
moment but I'm still stuck in my head of
what the [__] is this you know that I
didn't go wait I was in a moment of
History where I witnessed greatness and
I didn't take it all in yeah so that's
why I'm regretful and now I'm back at
Madison Square Garden this
what could have been yeah uh so then
what's your takeaway then for taika
you had to ask me what what did my
parental brain take away from my
personal experience so my biggest thing
is I want him to be present and I don't
want him to think there's a clock you
know because like that was my biggest
thing I thought like you had to graduate
college in four years or five years yeah
I love it or whatever and you look back
like when by the time I was 28 doing JK
full-time I'm like
whether or not I graduated college at 21
25 28 didn't [__] matter what matters
is did I get full experience military
and completing it yeah and then full
experience college like in college you
didn't do that either I should have
studied abroad I should have done so
many things but I just had these
imaginary timelines that by the time you
get to that age it doesn't matter so for
taika I want to have no timelines it's
so cool just whatever you're doing if
you're in it squeeze all the juice out
of that lemon he's got a strong grip and
then move on you know and then and then
move on when you felt like you squeezed
all the juice out of it yeah that's so
CUNY I love that I have so many half
squeezed lemons in my life that I'm like
God damn it there's so much juice left
oh
well I don't know I'll I'll help you as
much as I can to squeeze out from maybe
a new lemon that might
I don't know help for the other ones
that were half squeezed thank you okay
squeeze your lemons no baby you're gonna
help me yeah no not my lemons you could
squeeze your own lemons I'm talking
about your lemons broth ones are
cherries excuse me what they're that
small
yeah okay
okay well anyway on that note is there
anything else you want to add nope okay
anything else you want to add yep thank
you guys for watching this it was really
cool
um getting personal with you guys
because a lot of these are kind of like
husband and wife thoughts but it was
cool that through this uh Geo has
learned even more about me and I I would
say that's the lesson to all of you guys
like a lot of us especially growing up
in immigrant families you have like a
very like arbitrary timeline I gotta do
this by this just by this none of it
matters experience the most out of your
life be in the moment and um that way
because you never know when the same
opposition opportunity is gonna present
itself so make sure you squeeze the
juice when you have the fruit in your
hand and also if you want to support me
and Geo the best way is go to our
website barbara.com
um that brand makes this podcast
possible we got supplements we got
apparel we got
um
programs we've got equipment and then
our YouTube channel Barbara Brigade we
always have all kinds of Fun Fitness
content see you guys next time bye